okay for people who are joining the
livestream we are talking about some
post version 12 or from language
features and this particular one has to
do with creating web pages with multiple
panels and where are we at right now so
is this runnable no that's kind of a
design example that Eric Shu and I have
been talking together so one one note is
we did have a meeting last April about
the panel language and decided to kind
of cut off half the project and focus on
the web item aspect mainly for exporting
to HTML instead of trying to unify the
the two interfaces well I understand
that but I think that's what make sure
you're starting from no no we're
starting from the same place I mean the
issue is that we had hoped to be able to
UM to take a look at my notes
okay
this is horrifyingly oh this is from
january of 2017 um okay so what so
there's a client switched mechanism in
the new version right no we haven't
that's but that's essential that's
without that it doesn't make any sense
without that there's nothing there I
mean I don't stop this done this with
clients which and and and and and and
web by them were like designed to give
you like a way to translate CSS
deviations it's just just the styling
yeah what the heck is that and an HTML I
think it's a way to write HTML is
something completely different this
doesn't make any sense
this isn't what we were talking about
what we were talking about on what you
had Ricardo can you bring back up your
the thing that you had created
previously that you were able to demo or
search it yes yeah because that was what
we were trying to finish I don't know
what we what we starting off on some
committee different direction makes no
sense what we the conclusion we came to
is that a lot of the previous effort
while still usable a lot of the design
was still focused on the multi you know
I don't this is not what we want to do
what where did this come from
so in meetings about web item
effectively we have been focusing on the
problem of being able to create
basically export pages and CSS from the
language okay but I don't really say I
mean this is amusing but this is
incredibly low level and not very useful
right so this is part of the approach
that you and I have been talking about
but okay I think this approach doesn't
make any sense I mean I'm sorry I just
don't think I mean yes this is the you
know what's the difference in this and
just using XML HTML is a little bit
higher level a little bit
then hold on so so you I assume no and I
assume Eric is on the school right Eric
is here yes and I assume you know in
detail how our existing xml system works
is that correct
well so does this follow the same design
or not because if it doesn't that again
is completely crazy right I mean it you
reinvented something else that's
basically exactly like XML element but
it isn't XML amo hey that's it this one
HTML has attributes third in the content
second XML has that should be a second
in the content third sorry said it again
the second that their arguments are sort
of switched that's stupid why just
roughed in I didn't no no I understand
but did you not know her external
element works mmm I didn't look at the
documentation so that's wrong that's
wrong so what are you doing here I may
love them just providing something that
is basically just like this well but I
was thinking that HTML and would do some
additional things first
XML element doesn't probably doesn't
handle like all the styles and classes
and stuff like that so I was just thing
that we can build in additional
functionality that basically can you can
write styles and you know camelcase or
whatever and it will be able to
interpret it and then spit out the
correct no in my youth you've made your
own completely your own design you
haven't you paid no attention to all the
work we did previously you paid no
attention to XML element you just made
it a new design is that correct correct
I think it's just a waste of time I just
believe in this at all I certainly they
can be brought into parity without too
much effort but why are you showing me
something well you didn't do any
homework on it
so far no elements I mean you didn't
even look at the thing that we already
have there's almost identical to this
you apparently didn't look at the
previous panel language design
Ricardo did you get your demo ready in
session my found out yes and yeah
do you want me to show screen go why
don't you just send it to me because I
think okay then now we'll forward you
damn it so the approach I've been
working Eric and I have been going you
have you read all this stuff as well
from 2015
I remember going through some of that
last year when we were still talking
about panel language the approach here
is more from ground up with HTML element
and web item to build things that will
be useful for you know panel in the
panel language direction but have their
own uses as well for users so it can
kind of be an incremental development
and support things that people are
already used to rather don't understand
how it relates to the other design yeah
yeah the the the designs will absolutely
need to be brought into parity this is
more of a conceptual okay so what is
this doing other brush is providing a
symbolic version of angle bracket
you know tag etc that's primarily what
HTML element is very straightforward
supposed to be a web developer would
understand how to use of a templates lot
ideas so that that's that's something
how does the template get applied here
so the concept of the web item is
something like a named template of HTML
elements so in this case what Eric is
showing is if we had made a template for
a blog post for example it would be a
web item template would be nested HTML
elements with template slots so that you
could say template apply and put in your
content put in your links how can you
say template apply because this is not a
I type the template apply deals with
template apply deals with XML but it
doesn't deal with this so you know
template apply what's on any expression
because when you do string template or
XML amplitude with written as an
expression it parses it immediately
things just 3 and then it's it's a 3 of
an expression with templates lot and
then in social function combiner
function are are basically rendering so
you're saying like back to a string so
you're saying that if I set this whole
expression here and I then you do
template apply example basically raise a
blue blaze Olaf yeah yeah templates lot
with context and so the two things we
want to just convey what does this
generate this generates a raw string
here how does it do that you would be
able to export that I don't understand
how do you buy wait you need a combiner
function to do that not sure how these
ease people had that one yeah so I mean
is this run no I don't know why doesn't
run it looks trivial why isn't it just
three lines of code or something did you
write the three lines of code or not no
this is again a conceptual level sketch
of a design recorded you send me the
thing that you had before yeah
you
I should run on a recent field if you if
you run the Association code and then
you you run that back stick packet
template stuff showing our webpage for
you
I remember just let me get myself set up
here
um
[Music]
you
okay you're saying if I run which this
here know that you're ready run it then
regular examples just run the first line
and a new browser window should pop up
now I'm not sure on which screen since
your gosh yeah
it's okay so something popped up right
there okay yeah okay now what well
that's you can run the other code and
and see how it looks on a browser
okay so then here
you
okay
so this is now responsive well it's not
using interface which here so everything
is absolute there but if you find
examples with interface which it should
it should reside yes looks very flexible
layout let's try that this is still
fixed in a sense they is not responsive
if you go down there should be something
with yeah you see where it says
automatic column represents the browser
and yeah and so like the designers was
that web by them the first argument is
the is the content is the actual payload
and the second argument is the design
specification now specification can be
absolute and so you can say something
like scale or you can have an absolute
with one clear stuff pixel and whatever
are you gonna use interface reached you
doing quite nice and yeah when interface
when when the compiler sees interface
which it compiles to CSS specification
that uses media where in order to and so
the whole code is static is that it
doesn't use JavaScript here it's I
understand securely using CSS yeah I
think this is quite nice now what what's
involved in simply finishing this
what is the world the the the the
nesting of those expression are quite
complicated and the implementation I was
having was working quite nicely for a
lot of cases but yes like some weird
corner cases that needs to be cleaned
and some testing other than that like
the design needed to be cleaned up there
was like some kind of Pinterest design
yeah and yeah okay
so now in the setup if I wanted to embed
one of our forms and here how would I do
that
well the form was designed to be
full-page and so you can embed a form
object and it will render somehow into
the page there was also designed to to
create basically a a dynamic page with
with a context I don't know if it's in
this notebook if you go down try to go
down and okay let's just understand what
this was was a way of deploying I mean
the main point here was to be able to
deploy a multi panel interface with a
symbolic specification right yes the the
original design was more concerned about
creating dashboards and so I was more
concerned about like you know you have
like a page with four panels and you can
resize and so what is this one this is
something this is like some kind of blog
layout where you have like a sidebar and
another
yeah um and this was generated
dynamically with random word here yes
yes it was just generated so it's
generated with an HTTP response now now
if I wanted okay so does read more do
something okay it so it went to just
a hyperlink there but now what if I
wanted something where
[Music]
I mean what if I wanted to for example
embed a notebook on this page either in
better form so that we've got three
technologies here that we're dealing
with we've got the raw HTML technology
which is what you're showing here with
its CSS we've got our forms technology
which is again raw the forms have some
JavaScript is that correct our form
right JavaScript right and then the
third day they work even without
jaskeath but yeah okay
and the third technology we've got is
our full cloud notebook technology boy
at work so large a script
yeah right which thanks to yawns new
system has JavaScript embeddable as a
javascript embeddable version right is
yawn on the school YUM we can we can
embed cloud notebooks on the page with
some JavaScript library so in other
words it it's great since when since
about a month ah yeah um and it doesn't
work yet against the production cloud it
will need 150 ok so oh I didn't know
that actually ok but that's but so then
what would happen here is that you would
be able to in this layout you will be
able to put a notebook specification and
that notebook specification I mean you
need a backing notebook in the cloud
presumably but then that notebook would
appear as just one of the one of the
items here and it would appear it will
be resizable and everything's that
correct right so so right now you need
an actual cloud notebook so you need to
specify a URL and yeah if you can
configure it the way you want but you
can make it so that it's responsive and
just fills up whatever size you give it
in ok so so then within that notebook I
you know I put my mouse inside that
notebook I typed something and I press
shift enter things will happen inside
that notebook correct well no
unfortunate that doesn't work at it it's
the it's using to deployed you
essentially so it I say read it
obviously and you can enter
there's no editing and no evaluating so
it doesn't it's not something roll cuz
this is it a scrolling object too or no
ah that depends a bit if you give it
infinite heights then it will just use
whatever it needs otherwise it will
introduce the scrollbar yep so in other
words you specify it's either either a
fixed height or it will just insert
itself with whatever height it needs
yeah okay but do you think that in the
future you can make those embeddable
notebooks be editable um it's it's
certainly conceivable uh it needs some
bigger changes to our security model
basically there's there's some concerns
you know basically need a kernel sandbox
that need are tied to the owner of the
notebook nor the viewer okay um why
aren't you just tying it to some UUID
that's generated on that browser
instance we could maybe work around
things some way like that yeah okay
butBut then okay let's come back to the
forms stuff okay so it is I assume
Ricardo straightforward to insert one of
our forms in your system
is that true ie well I I don't know your
presentation I guess it is what III
guess should be set forward I mean if
it's just JavaScript and but you wrote
the form stuff so you know have fun
sorry I was thinking about notebooks the
fun phones are already supported yes
okay so can you show me an example which
has formed
oh yeah now that that was just showing
this is your reimplementation of that
site is that correct correct yeah I
don't take care of anything here with uh
with a form inside a shoe some things do
that click - how did you do the click
thing which I mean how did you do the
drag does this is this operable this
thing here so what will be involved to
make it operable well that that
implementation was using custom
JavaScript so you you you bright here on
JavaScript there in a top-level language
there is no implementation through
something like this I guess okay all
right so let's sketch okay
so then a thing that I've never
understood is if you have three forms on
a page what is the control flow
well for that we there are several way
even you can think about it when waited
for your thinking is that basically you
just replace the phone with the content
or you display the content underneath
each form it really depends anyway or
you could go to a completely separate
page or that yeah because because for
example it is a search form you want to
on a separate page okay which we think
those are the two cases that either you
are using the form to generate something
like a form page which is you know this
like an embedded form page versus a form
function which would go to a separate
page is that kind of the thought because
most of it on one page gets one form and
and yes they don't know a response and
then there are other forms but they are
kind of independent they redirect to
other pages like such form and stuff
like that yes I think most of the time
okay all right another question here so
right now you know like if I take this
notebook just for fun and I say
published a cloud
okay I should get if I publish it here I
should get a notebook here we go um
let's go to an anonymous window here um
and I should get if everything works
correctly I should get a version of that
notebook in the cloud okay which is so
someone was asking on the live stream
transforming a notebook into a dynamic
website I mean that's kind of what this
is doing um and and presumably I can
just well this is a published notebook
but this is kind of ugly why does it
look maybe maybe you just tell it was
ugly originally that's ugly now okay um
so and if I wanted
yes so now the other technology that we
have had is the transmogrify technology
for generating things like documentation
pages where there is no expectation that
anything will be active right and where
we just using click to copy but where we
have the advantage that it's pure HDL I
mean what has happened with the you know
what does this look like to an HTML only
if I switched off how do I see this as a
pure text how would I see this in like a
purely textual view without JavaScript
and so on so an easy way to do that
somebody you can see the HTML source but
that's not what you wanted this
that was not useful in fact really bad I
mean where is the thing that like a you
know a search engine could find where is
that but where is the actual material
from that the actual text
but you want to be a patient rather
colorful there's a browser plug and you
can probably install that removes all of
CSS and in JavaScript however why am I
not seeing in the HTML source why am I
not seeing some where the actual content
you would be if you search for it
at least the first part of it too
very human-readable I think is your
complaint Stephen and if I does give us
more human readable HTML output I mean
if we go for example to let's see if we
just go to the documentation some random
but the content of tea not of the
uneasiness is in the HTML or isn't part
of the JavaScript well that you won't I
won't see the full note for content in
either of them so there's what you get
initially within each place ml is the
first you few cells as HTML the rest is
loaded on demand both taste and data to
render it in a life way and HTML 4
for cells below the fold okay so and
obviously it's we don't make any effort
to you know line wrap things nicely and
indent stuff
in fact we deliberately choose not to do
that so your assertion is that if I were
to use our web crawl functionality and
try and extract things from these pages
that I will be able to extract
reasonable stuff from both both of these
pages like that page there if I do for
example let's just try it if I do and
that page if I do import of that page
oops not the view source part um import
that page comma now what would I want to
say I'd say want to say HTML for example
going to be total mess there will be
some garbage as well that's not bad at
all that's really not bad at all
I mean that's perfectly content is in
there there's also some other stuff and
this will also improve like this menu
you see the menu of the this sell gear
that the items nacelle gear menu
basically everyone should go away okay
on the page but but yeah that the
content is basically there for most
cells so so basically it takes the first
few cells and always includes them and
then pure textual cells will also be
there arm
why aren't you hotel yep you go well I'm
not sure that's the right decision but
but okay but let's look at this one by
comparison okay if you look at do not
look at the end of the visions like a
tentative design for adding metadata
like for search engine and stuff and
that that was the web page proper where
basically you know you you can have your
you wrap the content that can be like
you know a notebook and stuff and not
like custom external script or meta tags
that can be understood by search engines
right okay uh okay by the way the
comments on this live stream which I
think it's interesting to respond to
somebody's talking about panels on the
desktop that's a horrendously hard
problem because you can't run browser
type technology on the desktop with the
security models that exist um why don't
we release the HTML Javascript thing
that we use in cloud notebooks
quite sure what that means because the
whole thing is tied into servers I don't
think there's a thing I mean the the
JavaScript embedding mechanism is I
think maybe what Nicola is asking for
here is actually what we're currently
calling the Wolfram application server
um which is something you can install
somewhere that will provide a well no no
no because that doesn't support
notebooks that doesn't support notebooks
I don't support say api's um I think one
thing we can say is that the library to
embed cloud notebooks on other pages
that will be released so it will be
basically a thin wrapper that's even
gonna be open source
um and it's going to be on NPM and so on
but it will basically what it will take
is a URL to a cloud object and then it
will render that notebook on on your
website ROM so Ethan here is saying
generating HTML is easy the real problem
is there's no built-in way to parse raw
HTML it's interesting what parse as in
parse it into something which can then
be manipulated I assume so in other
words to do the analog of XML in port
right so if I import this page and I
import it what what happens if I do that
I mean if I import that page it's
probably a fairly large page but let me
try importing that page as XML what will
it do sometimes it works sometimes does
not the browser mean is that when you
import this XML XML is supposed to be
you know perfectly nested and the way
people are writing hTML is not and the
way the way browser understands in tags
and stuff probably we can have like some
kind of sloppy XML import that that is
what probably the browser is doing with
some automatic closed and of of what is
not closing tour so your client I spend
reason this is failing is but it's not
correct XML
right yeah also the design this is what
is happening people are riding yeah yeah
they brothers I've always been very
forgiving right and correct as efforts
to make HTML XML you know perfect have
never really carried through that much
so this is yeah there was they all X
HTML stuff them no one wanted to do is
it's just more work all the time so
Ethan here is talking about J soup and
appears to have aj soup link sounds
interesting which is doing what it's
then importing something so this is a
kind of a forgiving HTML importer of
some kind that will be useful I guess
that when you're doing import HTML
hyperbole in color or other elements
it's it is forgiving because there is
already some logic theories you know
passing the HTML in a way that like the
browser is doing what is HTML Dom is
that is that I I don't recall that being
one of our I mean this is an attack
would be no we don't have this this is
something new and different
ah okay all right now we've got a github
link to je soup link cool okay all right
this is great this is the this is the
best possible thing as if is if we're um
yeah okay this this looks like a bit
more bull we obviously should look at
this this looks like a very interesting
thing look at this HTML elements this is
cool
Wow very nice that's the easiest way to
do development is to other people do it
for us that's wonderful well I was also
thinking like if what is that this is
wonderful
okay go ahead now I was saying like I
was thinking like that when you do
import XML XML element is not really
human readable and and it will be nice
like if you go down like the wrists like
these three Explorer and maybe we should
do something like this in drop miles
well when you say sube exactly that
opens an interface but that was the
route well okay
so what this is doing then is it's using
an external importer and turning this
into something which is which has this
HTML element mechanism well that's
really interesting so the point being
made is that there's so then there's yet
another constraint here okay so let's
let's again let's let's zoom out for a
moment to what we're looking at here so
on the one hand there's if we could
construct some pretty raw HTML and just
say okay put it out as a page right and
we're doing that in a way that is more
tree structured more explicitly tree
structured not just a big blob of text
it's not completely obvious to me the
people we got excited about that because
if you know the thing we've got with XML
template allows you to write R or HTML
with just random you know string
inclusions for the forum for templating
I mean I'm not sure why this is an
advantage relative to just having I mean
if people are just gonna write R or HTML
I know I don't know whether ok that's
why yeah good
I also foresee so one of the one of the
tacks for taking Wolfram language
generated you know contents in cells is
to do something like a rewrite of
transmogrify so it can turn cell
structures into HTML element structures
and I think that having HTML element as
an in-between lets you know the the the
developer here if they have you know if
they're savvy in HTML they can do
customization in language before they do
exports so having that as kind of like
an in-between level where you know web
developers can really roll up their
sleeves even if they don't you know get
all the way there with Wolfram language
is kind of a way for web developers to
be able to but this tool right right but
ok by the way d8 on our live stream says
XML template it's pretty good though the
documentation is really bad
who here who wrote the documentation for
it
what is the well that I guess with me
[Music]
unfortunately XML template probably we
can use some of the new button we're
doing for documentation because there
are like slot and notes like that have a
particular syntax and it's true that is
hard to find them inside the
augmentation and and and you know there
is like XML he if or the for loop or or
a switch and history with this scheme of
the documentation is is too much
information a single page and we we
should probably split it right well
workflows are the obvious thing then one
of them but it sounds like tech notes
here would be useful to you know pseudo
tutorials right okay but so so
XML template does is it takes what is
essentially a textual lump of HTML with
included and I will be good if you
showed an example of that here by the
way I mean a slightly bigger piece of
HTML the problem here is that you don't
really bright it like this you most of
the time I mean this was the wrong and I
was renovation did most of the time you
you you want to write like those thing
unified directly and and like you have a
directory of files we with HTML inside
and using those tags and then it with
just five template or XML template or
file and then up to load it but you
don't really write it directly in the
notebook which is ready this is about
template or file does this yeah and I
think the way you want to use it most
diamonds to use XML template of file and
then like you know we don't we have five
textual I did not just just just studied
the the fish came out fine no that was
the obvious thing to do that that should
be described as you know tech note or a
workflow I would have thought of
workflow will be a perfectly reasonable
thing um but in any case okay but so the
problem this is solving is just review
what what's happening here so here
you've got a textually written out piece
of HTML with little inclusions that say
how things should be
you know templated in so to speak right
yes make sense now what this is doing is
taking this is providing a you know a
symbolic expression structured version
of what would otherwise be the purely
textual XML that's being specified an
XML template is that right
what's that looks to me now okay we have
the XML object excellent thing where you
can lay it out structurally but right I
don't think do we I mean so is this XML
template work with no you don't need to
use XML template if you're using XML
element because that's just a pure
template apply okay Canon by the XML
element inside is distinct and it will
it will compile them into XML
okay so Ethan while a live stream is
making the comment that XML XHTML is not
isomorphic to HTML and is is making the
case for a separate treatment of HTML
separate from the XML stuff and I mean
it sounds like there are two potential
reasons for that you know not the least
of them being that actual HTML in the
wild isn't xml compliant so true
statement
certainly right yes sir it depends a bit
which direction you want to go if you
want to parse existing HTML then you
certainly can't treat it as XML um you
know not even fully it's not very
standard compliant or not this HTML
standard is not compatible with with XML
and in all regards so to parse it you
certainly need to treat it specially but
to generate it I think it might be fine
you might get away with no I haven't it
bollock XML and then generating XML out
of it that's still valid HTML okay but I
mean we specifically didn't have a
function called HTML template because we
actually thought about this issue um and
but so oh okay so the source for let's
just walk through you know how do you
make a web page basically that's what
we're talking about here so let's let's
look at the various different ways you
can make a web page okay so one thing
you can do is export a notebook to the
cloud that's one way to make a web page
right which i think which can then be
embedded um I mean this is basically how
to make a web page
okay and then this which can then be
embedded through the JavaScript and
better what are we calling that
javascript embedding thing
yawn harder Wolfram notebook and better
um okay alright so our first item is
export a notebook to the cloud okay so
another one would be potentially export
an expression as HTML and that's using
the existing HTML export right
yes and we don't really like HTML
fragment is usually more useful and it's
limited okay but so this is using the
existing exporter okay the next thing we
can do is use XML template to inject
material into you know into an existing
HTML and we're a bit confused about HTML
vs XML structure is that correct that's
a less less fancy thing so so now we've
got on offer
then we've got Ricardo's almost seems
like some kind of oh well anyway um
Ricardo's web item symbolic description
you forgot the trademark that next to
Ricardo's well I was thinking with name
um item let's see um web icon symbolic
description of the page right and
which because of the notebook embedder
we could take essentially chrome this
would provide this is provides a way of
providing can provide essentially chrome
around around an embedded notebook or
multiple embedded notebooks that correct
yep and one thing I want to clarify is
that the JavaScript library you know
that the wolf remote can better really
just runs on the client side and embeds
the notebook by constructing Dom
elements and injecting them into the
page and so on if you want to serve
static HTML as part of the page
for the notes book then you need some
additional mechanism ah idling some
there's that embedded HTML that you're
talking about there or what what do you
so but this this requires okay so this
solution requires a background cloud so
it could be a public cloud it could be a
private cloud running in AWS it could be
all kinds of things like that but it
requires a you know a Wolfram cloud in
the background it's not a slight thing
enough friend that's truly interactive
can be standalone here right I mean not
until or unless we have web assembly and
all those kinds of fancy things
happening okay so so now we've got this
web item symbolic description and then
we've now got this new we've now got the
HTML we've got now this is Eric's HTML
element
symbolic description which is a much
which is a lower-level symbolic
description that a first statement I
mean I I don't quite understand I think
the main difference is Ricardo's has
focused on generating CSS and heiresses
focus on generating HTML well as
Ricardo's reconnaissance ESS at CSS with
HTML in it isn't right but maybe it's
just the examples he showed but they all
had pretty simple examples and then the
CSS was impressive but it seemed you
know all the cool stuff I saw seemed
like the effort wasn't you know this
isn't doing CSS this is doing pure HTML
yes Eric yes Eric's thing here is
focused on an authoring HTML although
there's certainly room for including CSS
that's a thing because that's a look to
me what you're doing here is providing
and I don't really understand the
advantage of it you're providing a tree
structured version of a file and an HTML
file well I just think that this is one
representation we could use a file like
if you wanted to write an entire HTML
file with you know slots to put stuff in
you could but why is that any different
from what XML template is already doing
well it's not the same thing but why not
I mean other than that okay um okay
butBut
that's
difference in the structure of XML and
HTML is that correct yes
okay so then okay things to make
potentially um potentially one thing to
make is HD HTML element I'm sorry XHTML
template
I think log of XML temp the way I use
we're using air canary using web item is
as an HTML template but it's a named
template yes the idea behind it was that
if so if we're designing a web page with
very you know common styles they're
saying a blog post it was kind of the
example here is that web item would be
templates of individual pieces of the
site that you know that this is some
author would be let's go in just plop in
and injury place all the content all the
styles would be defined you would just
be able to plop in these named objects
and then just change the content what is
this okay so so this thing here is this
one so this one this one first example
is kind of the wrapper around the whole
webpage so that's just you know this
defining blog template or is this using
blog template this is defining blog
template that's totally we that part of
the design is something we want to we
discuss in more depth yeah but that's
completely weird okay so yeah
registration you're saying okay so hold
on so you're saying there's there's a
something you might want is a library of
or repository obviously a my mind for
for these things right repository of
useful HTML templates right that would
be a that would be a thing that one
could make in which case the way this
would look is it would say just like you
know interestingly we you know just like
we have resource data we could
potentially have I don't know whether
this makes sense quite resource template
or whatever and it would be something
like template apply of resource template
comma
and then some set of you know the
parameters that you wants to put in
there right yeah yeah something along
those lines
okay I already know the namespace yeah
okay
so so then this the concept of an HTML
element is so so then there's another
thing which is importing of HTML for
which we have that very beautiful github
um J soup well that wasn't there wasn't
the name of the actual um um okay so
importing of HTML to a symbolic
representation so what one would
presumably want and I'm a little
confused by that I mean that had an HTML
element but I don't understand how deep
it goes and you know in other words
Dom another example it looked like you
could you can take an out HTM element
and then grabbed all the children that
look like so it's kind of like a entire
structure okay great trail breakdown so
that is a so then the HTML element and I
wonder how that relates to what we're
doing with web execute okay so questions
um
you
relation to web execute and the way it
handles the Dom you know I'm saying um
okay so just two let's see the proper
thing to do is turn HTML and I'm reading
from our live stream comments here from
d8 the proper thing to do is to turn
HTML into Dom which is what we saw
earlier with with J soup yes that that
that makes sense although turning it
into an opaque I mean that was turning
it into what appeared to be an opaque
Dom that is for which you could go and
explore different pieces as opposed to
something which is an unrolled symbolic
expression here does that make sense to
people
this here is just saying one could
imagine instead of this and I'm going to
take a screenshot of this nice thing um
the UM instead of this one could imagine
something which unrolls this thing into
a symbolic structure that looks like
this am I making sense
yes right um okay so the question there
is should it unroll into a full symbolic
structure or leave opaque blobs effect
effectively we never just be a
formatting question right no I don't
think so because I think these Dom blobs
well I don't know if that's a for
hunting question I don't know whether
it's unraveled
to a to symbolic form all the way down
and that might be undesirable for all
kinds of reasons so it seems like there
are okay so to summarize here there are
three representations
okay so representations of a web page of
HTML slash web pages okay so one
representation is you know plain text of
the HTML plus whatever it contains plus
inclusions okay
the next would be symbolic Dom objects
like this the next would be symbolic
HTML element tree and the next would be
web item like symbolic elements is that
a fair statement that's sort of a
hierarchy of different forms there
I'm a writer man what's the difference
between Dom object and dhtml elementary
because in this one I'm thinking that
these are opaque objects of the kind
that for example web execute would
return that you don't necessarily this
isn't immediately a thing where you can
go and use you know position or
something on it so I'm saying
does that make sense yawn mmm okay to
look but wouldn't you understand it it's
really important you understand it okay
so one the question is when this is
brought into the language right if I if
I go web execute and I look if I if I
run web execute remember how to do this
but if I run web execute and I say
something like um you know if I do this
okay
then the thing I get back yeah web
session objects for example these things
or what works someplace here I should
get a web element yeah this thing here
right see that a web element object that
is opaque you get what I'm saying okay I
think I understand now
so it's handles that you can use other
API is on but but they're not
expressions that contain everything
exactly whereas whereas here we've got
something that's fully unrolled and it
you know we could reconstruct we just
pick up the content of the notebook and
we can reconstruct the the web page
whereas here you pick up the content of
the notebook and the thing might have
gone you know who knows where it is yep
got it um mmm
okay so it's
a browser then I think I don't know
whether it's tied to a browser I'm not
sure I'm not sure could be try to a
browser or could be or could be local
data but just not in symbolic form I
don't know I mean I I don't know what
I'd like to know what this some thing on
github does but you get what I'm saying
because it might be the case that this
thing is something opaque to our
language where you can't run position on
it for example and see something inside
it yeah okay or it might be either
because it's not local or because and
it's just a handle or because it's
simply opaque right because for example
if what this contained underneath was
essentially a text file you wouldn't be
able to run position looking for a
symbolic HTML elements in that right
yeah okay it's also creating a front-end
using something like react and a pile of
api's well I believe that creating a
front-end using react is exactly what we
just spent years doing under Yuans
leadership here um let's see converting
that data routine for notebooks at least
yeah I'm not sure if this is referring
to uh you know defining something using
HTML elements but also in combination
with JavaScript I see right like if you
wanted to click to copy tool that you
could wrap around an HTML element or web
item right that might be done for
JavaScript and it would be one of these
reasons yeah so the idea is like yeah
there was an auto copy of Y by item
template I had an example that's
basically what would be from the blog
well of course you would have to have
the Java Script that would back that
functionality but at least you have the
right template would be able to put in
the auto copy right and we that's react
has components was what they call them
there for things like that from what I
understand
okay so limit the eight is saying good
writing HTML is useful but have been way
more useful for included CSS and
JavaScript with it something like react
components will be super nice so I I
think you mean converting to HTML um and
Mohamed says please do something about
the notebook history GUI actually I just
was looking at that yesterday and we're
about to have some programmatic ways to
access the history that will be in the
function repository soon um
okay maybe HTML elements is a poor name
since what you're wanting to do is turn
a string of HTML into a symbolic
representation of a Dom tree and then to
turn the Dom tree back to HTML yeah well
right I mean this is these are low-level
raw HTML elements whereas one could
imagine here yeah this is called HTML
elements and maybe this should be
instead called you know I don't know
whether HTML Dom elements or something
I'm not sure whether that um
I don't fully understand that okay let's
let's um zoom out again for a second
okay
so okay let's let's look at what we have
what we want to get so first we have
Ricardo's web item stuff which really
seems like it's a pretty good idea I
don't see a reason why we wouldn't
finish building that I mean does anybody
think that there's a that that's a bad
direction for some reason
I think my main criticism for either
using Ricardo stuff or Yan stuff is that
there's little room for someone who
knows the HTML to come in and that's a
different issue that's a different issue
because you're asking if they want to
write raw HTML how do they do it how do
they merge raw HTML with some one of
these things is that right right if they
know HTML and they say ok so the answer
were news on no no no no no no the
answer is yan just provided an answer to
that for notebooks right it's a fairly
complicated thing to embed but he has
provided an embedding mechanism now we
don't have that embedding mechanism for
example for our forms do we like
something from a form function how do
you embed that in an HTML page is using
an iframe no but I mean if I say embed
code of a form function I don't think it
will work it would give you your iframe
doesn't give you an iframe it deploys it
okay so one of the issues is what's on
top HTML or our stuff so in other words
actually there's so so kind of layering
is the issue so one model would be you
know hTML is on top um and you've
written most of your page in it you just
want to embed some data of content
that's one case the other case is WL
content is on top you want to embed raw
HTML + etc in it
is that a fair assessment that there are
those two cases the second case is what
we haven't been in html4 right that is
Indian that that embedded HTML
contributes to that um okay so this case
here hTML is on top
that's essentially um yawns well it's
the it's the wool from notebook embedder
is one by the way we probably should put
that in the spell-checking dictionary if
we're really going to use that um the
so
you
that's one case for this the other case
for this is the the templating
mechanisms XML template etc so correct
because then you're effectively writing
the HTML and embedding through a
template there
so for example one thing we might want
to do is to have XML template
interoperate with yarns notebook and
better other words so that the combiner
function of XML template if you give it
a notebook does the notebook embedding
did that make sense
yup we need to decide what the head is
basically no if you put a cloud object
there should it always assume it's gonna
be a notebook or maybe some have some
other right but so that's actually an
interesting action item that we that we
want to be able to take you know we want
to be able to get the text of an HTML
like page but but actually put you know
insert a notebook on it and in fact we
don't have yeah okay but that's okay
that's okay all right now let's so the
statement being made oh you know how to
write HTML so we want to make it easy
for you to do stuff explain which of
these are you talking about there
I'm Eric could you please explain what
you were thinking of
so explain which part sorry about that I
was just asking about I'd say it's
probably the first one this one here you
can yeah like you can write an HTML
template and you want to you know take a
notebook generate a graph or a chart you
know one time not dynamic and have a way
to embed that into the HTML that you've
already written into that structure
right so that so really this is not what
you want you just want I don't want to
all this junk I'm just writing my HTML
and a text editor or something or some
other you know HTML writing system and
all I want is to be able to take the
content from us and embed it so so part
of this is simply getting the embed code
stuff I mean that that's it really
straightforward stuff it's just embed
code to make an iframe you just stick
that you know in your HTML you just know
what that what that embed code is and
you push put it in your HTML right that
solves that problem doesn't it you only
is life frame which makes sense for some
things right but so we've got now the
two cases this embed code which part
that already works for the images and
PNG and stuff you know all the static
content you need if you if you have
interactivity I guess okay so you're
saying just pure export goes to things
like JPEG and so on right this is a
hierarchy so so we've got if it's just a
static JPEG everybody knows how to deal
with that it lives in a in a location in
the cloud well you export so this would
be something like a cloud export gives
you a URL for the JPEG you can then
stick into your HTML and the HTML you
write and you're happy right this case
is slightly more complicated it's an
iframe
that would give you embed code for and
that embed code could be for for
manipulate can it be for a form
can it be for a forum function would be
iframed okay but is that the right thing
to do for a forum function maybe not
always but but certainly sometimes okay
so that remains a question then how to
embed a forum function output um there's
also in between those things there's
where you want to export static content
for stuff where we still need to make it
work like say tab view you don't want to
I frame it cuz web has tab views right
so you know converting Wolfram language
whether it's front-end stuff okay okay
all right so this is um okay so there's
an additional case you say which is
converting UI elements WL UI elements eg
tab view to native HTML or just formats
you know traditional form tax things
like that yeah all these expansions on
HTML export HTML export yes yes but
that's but HTML export is fundamentally
going to give you I don't even know it's
time what it gives you just to give you
a citizen it gives you a directory of
stuff is that correct
yeah okay which is actually not
particularly convenient and you might
very well want HTML export to export to
the cloud because you just want a bunch
of URLs right this is where our products
have been using andis transmogrify yeah
right for a lot of things because it you
know digs through things and finds the
best okay so let's talk about that for a
second what about HTML export creating
URLs on the cloud ok let's talk about
transmogrify for that okay so
transmogrify we use for our
documentation builds
and that's um and what does it do
I mean it's probably a giant hack tower
built over a quarter of a century by now
Andre can you comment on that yeah it's
I would express it somewhat similarly to
what was being said about the HTML
element thing which is you know to to
give somebody who has more expertise
with HTML or CSS the means to use
Wolfram language to get stuff done can
you show us to transmogrify in action
can somebody show us I'm not prepared to
do that but Andy could or maybe if Bob
has it on his Bob do you have something
good can somebody try and reach out to
Andy see if he can come and join us I'm
here
I don't have the it's gonna take a while
to do that but I mean we're talking
about a build process and I can describe
to you what it does so you know it takes
no book or cell structures and it's
through them and finds parts that are
easily exported to HTML and so let's
look at a destination page as an example
okay what something these three
restaurants it puts it in a dedicated
image folder and then it creates HTML
that points to that image okay but you
find custom CSS it allows you to find
custom mappings from okay page more like
rule sets right you have a left-hand
side which would be a head of cell in
their right hand side which would be XML
element what's the right hand side is
that what you're generating as output
yes okay so so what it's doing so let's
talk about what this is some how to wake
a web page so there's another is
transmogrify you know from the very name
we already know yes I mean it was named
advisedly so to speak um okay so so it's
fundamental thing is take a sequence of
cells is that a first step
and make quotes optimal HTML from them
is that right sure it takes one
structure and turns it into another
structure based on rules that you create
cells or is it is it doing it from
notebook head notebook head cell held
edsel group right so each one of those
so there is a function transmogrify
which can take a single cell and do
something with it yes so for example if
I look at this document here so for
example I could pull up the source for
this um it's like cell style notes maybe
so I mean this is already pretty
complicated here so you've got code that
somehow transmogrifies this into that
yes for a cursor so it starts and then
dies down but but the key point is
there's flexibility in the rules to
optimize the conversion for how we write
our H some of those rules I mean so I'm
sure that there's a lot of very specific
stuff in there like for example if we go
down here
I mean I've no idea whether some of
these some of these outputs like output
line 9 they're uh well I don't know what
is line 9 it isn't even line 9 it's
rerun itself right or did it rerun or
did it automatically just generate these
and it remembers itself on the fly okay
so that's another little you know
feature at there okay so here for
example this is probably pure H no it's
not it's an image okay because we use
copy to clipboard for the inputs why
don't we doing copy to clipboard for the
outputs we could copy to clipboard with
the option of
adding the output no no that's not what
I want I want if I go over the output
why doesn't it just offer me a copy to
clipboard it's not doing anything else
for me here there I was saying if you
want both no I would you should
shouldn't have to copy twice I don't
that's all necessary that's that's its
own different thing I think you'll want
the outputs for different reasons than
you want the the inputs okay so so what
this is doing to be clear is it's taking
a notebook and it is making pure HTML
with JavaScript and another funky stuff
in it but it's doing a lot of
transformations here right right and
it's creating these custom things like
these openers which are probably some
special piece of JavaScript right and
it's making the decision to put that
there with a number 16 there and so on
and so on and so on so there's tons of
stuff there right okay there's metadata
for each of the notebooks that gets run
through to help inform any of that stuff
but okay but what is the user level
version of this that we can imagine
being useful I mean well you know
obviously for what we're trying to do
going forward for repositories and
documentation and sort of user level
docu tools we're gonna need something
like this but why aren't we generate so
what is the trade-off between taking
this as a cloud notebook do I do I dare
to do the obvious thing Here I am going
to do it I am going to do it I want to
see what happens this is thing the main
trade-off is you don't need a cloud to
back the result of this but static yeah
this should have a some kind of some
progress indicator yes progress
indicator how did you read my mind for
that I don't know okay well mark is
whether the the stylesheet will be there
it's not just happened what just
happened I like that was a big win
okay I closed I closed that notebooks
before I'd copied out well I guess I can
go to my cloud account and go to where
am I going cloud files and then I would
go to published write this one here and
then I would go to how do I sort it who
I sort the top right corner it's sort of
practically no but sort by date created
I want there we go why did it come up
with that sidebar oh because I'm in the
in the product for you and it looks like
the stylesheet is is not there I guess
right right okay but this stuff is not
super embarrassing here it's also the
authoring notebook though so there's a
kind of what it looks like right I mean
this is far from embarrassing what we've
got out here we don't have clicked
because that's not what this does right
well maybe if I'd looked at the deployed
view right this is this is a user view
an own of you it is but I think the you
still wouldn't see it for the input
because you can you know nicely select
them yes by the way there's a bug for
you whatever that is matrix plot take a
look at it but now here I see that's
just a bitmap why is that maybe that was
a bitmap in the source probably was else
okay
whereas now what do you know it's all
active right right so I mean this is not
embarrassing and the trade-off here you
know if I look at the scrolling of this
it's not terrible I I mean it you know
so the question is can we use well why
is that why is it not present why is the
stuff as I scroll backwards why does it
have any cross hatching yarn well there
is this trade-off between putting
everything into the Dom or not and we
decided to not put everything on the
page you know plus minus from the
current viewport so there is this short
asynchronous step where we put things
into the Dom again as you scroll for
this okay so look the trade-off is
between this and a completely
transmogrified thing that has somehow
converted to the closest raw HTML right
because yeah and what is the can the
difference between the cached version in
the isomorphic react cache of this page
and the raw HTML which something like
transmogrify might generate so first of
all the way we can rate the cache right
now and what what you would get by
default is that it only
contains a few cells as we discussed
before um there will be a way to
generate an HTML cache for the whole
page for all cells if that's what you
want okay mostly relationship between
HTML cache in HTML export output and
then I mean it's just the way it's
generated basically that the HTML code
uses our JavaScript from then to produce
HTML uh and so you know what if I can I
just pick up that HTML and go take it
somewhere else or is it deeply entangled
with a bunch of JavaScript libraries um
the HTML isn't really tied to JavaScript
libraries no um but it will use some
URLs that are tied to the cloud for
style sheets and for things like
graphics that we factor out into into
separate file ok but but ok but so let's
walk through this because this is really
interesting ok so what you're telling me
is that the technology we've built with
great effort so we've got two
technologies we've got HTML export which
is very old technology that directly
just generates HTML but it has many
limitations right now we've got the
modern system for making active cloud
notebooks which also as a side effect is
generating HTML but that hTML is
pointing off in some cases to some
either active elements or just
separately stored our own elements just
like HTML export has to make a whole
folder of assets right you're saying
yeah this thing has trailing assets that
are off in the cloud you know so do any
of these things
so HTML export has trailing assets that
are often some other folder right right
mm-hmm
okay so my question now is if I look at
the HTML that's being generated by your
technology stack and I look at the HTML
that's being generated by and I'm gonna
ask about two others HTML export and
transmogrify let me just understand from
andy transmogrify an HTML export are
those different technology stacks or are
they the same they're different
boy with similar like to see them be the
same in the future yeah we need to
converge that's right so maybe we should
ants matter if I has more hooks for the
people trying to customize that that's
the main difference okay but but maybe
we shouldn't be looking at either of
those and maybe we should be looking at
using Yuans technology stack and
basically having it be able to generate
so the the main criticism of that okay
the big advantage of Yuans technology
stack is there's just sort of a slider
you can move that determines just how
active and how dependent on sort of
external cloud assets and so on in other
words should the manipulates run if yes
you've got no choice but to actually go
interact with the cloud if no you can
turn them into bitmaps
but in Yuans technology stack as I
understand it that's just kind of a you
know a knob you can turn whereas in
these other technology stacks like
exporting raw HTML export you're just
out of luck if there's I'm gonna be like
there
it's got to be bitmapped so no I mean
there can certainly down the road for
exporting things with with dynamic
elements there can certainly be a place
where the two technologies cannot I know
but I would love to throw away you know
the I'd love to get rid of a second HTML
export technology I agree with that but
just to be clear that we did make it
possible to do HTML export with
manipulates as embedded objects that
were supported by player when it's
supported you know embedding but right
but so in principle they could use yawns
modern embedded notebook and better
right they could they could yes and that
would be an alternate pathway would be
to use the HTML export system with that
help looking better okay so let's go
back again oh just one more comment but
a huge win for going with yawns
direction is that
we already are going to be updating the
cloud constantly with new as new
features I know I know
Marie right but so the question is
what's the downside
and what yon is saying is with his
technology stack he could generate a
static HTML page
is that correct Yann a complete static
HTML page
yeah that's correct and I was already
considering um you know just having a
standalone JavaScript binary library
basically that that would produce local
files for you if that's what you want
don't think you know you explain that I
don't understand that I don't understand
that comment you're saying I'll run an
electron or something will to run in
some nodejs or something like that yeah
you just executed by a notice for
instance but the main point being that
it wouldn't generate assets in the cloud
for say graphics but produced a local
file instead
okay so it's a wait a minute so what
you're saying there is your technology
stack could produce a modern version of
what HTML export does that true which in
their directory of stuff that you could
point your that if you put it in a file
on your local machine you could point
your web browser at it and it would sing
and dance is that right yeah with a bit
of work we could we could hook it up
that way mm-hmm okay so now walk me
through the downside of this so HTML
export is purely code that can run on
any local machine do you have a version
of that um let me think so it would have
to be it would certainly be some
JavaScript code also would be running in
node.js on a local machine yes and then
there is that there are still some
things that need the cloud back-end I'll
let need to think about that how how
cool that is those things but but I
think the assertion would be that those
things you're out of luck for those
things with the traditional HTML export
right there anything that ok assertion
which may not be true that anything
where your system actually needs a cloud
to be present you simply couldn't do
with the old HTML export header on time
for sure but I'm see even at HTML
generation time you know that the way
our system works is it's it's the
JavaScript piece that usually runs in a
browser we're running nodejs but then
there is still the the cloud server
aspect which is a bunch of Java code
that basically acts as a as a
man-in-the-middle between JavaScript and
the kernel and I have to think about how
how significant that is I mean we
because really make it work but there
might be something that that don't work
okay so one path here okay so then let's
walk through transmogrify as it now is
which is transmogrify is is if I'm
understanding correctly the fancy
but not end-user usable version of HTML
export is that a fair statement a
different different codebase but that's
it's that's it's specifically targeted
to notebooks and cell expressions right
right then um using version 4 +
technology it hasn't been really updated
for that many years yeah how old is it
it was written for person Y it was
written using version 4 so that's like
1996 7 okay it's 20 years old amazing um
okay well alright so so it needs to be
replaced
but but um but the other thing that
you're saying about it is it has many
hooks to customize the HTML that is
generating yes and those hooks are so
how easy would it be jaan to put special
hooks into your HTML generator hmm if
you're thinking about you know adding
CSS class names and and having custom
definitions for them that would not work
well for at least in general so for
instance you know if you want to change
the font size of thumb of something that
would affect the layout but then in our
rendering of the notebook
we usually rely on an absolute position
of everything so things wouldn't adjust
to some custom CSS definition so the
transformative nature of it just
wouldn't be there you you would have to
create your notebook to look like what
you want it to be as HTML right that
that would certainly be one option is
that realistic for us I mean that would
require a brand I don't think so yeah
there's there are still many things that
we get from HTML that we don't get in
notebooks right now and then we don't
necessarily even want to notebooks
just the three people once on the web
but they don't yeah um alright well
that's a down over so okay right now if
you took the same notebook and put it
through the reference transmogrify it
would be different than the research
system transmogrify we already have
different tools here I think the whole
business of web by name was to be do
responsive website because in the end of
the front-end is very good at doing
something that is absolute position at
and and but we don't really have
anything in the notebook that scales
with the notebook size and what is one
structure yeah and and and and and so
like what biden was always good because
you analyze the window okay explain to
me andy in others the transmogrify
output is is responsive right because
we've got a whole responsive system for
doing documentation output and so on
right well it's just because you convert
it to HTML that is written except
irresponsible answer via right but that
HTML style it is the target of the you
know transmogrify rules must have been
changed to allow responsiveness is that
correct
yes okay
okay let me look at some of these
comments on our live stream here
so d8 says to audiences one who wants to
embed notebooks in a simple style way
and the other is web developers to take
processed data and turn it into a custom
web page yeah I kind of agree um there
is also like one other big discussion
we're having all the time we were
designing the this whole framework which
is how do you do like dynamic content
and and there was idea to use like
dynamic dynamic module and compile it
somehow so that you end up with
something that is reactive
you know the whole reactive idea that is
beyond reactive you and and so 50
something that is very similar to
dynamic that that we have in the
language for how many years now but we
don't have a way to translate that into
and you know use dynamic to to basically
generate a web page and we let's take
about minimal page okay so the minimal
case will be a dynamic of now for
example to put a clock there so I don't
know enough about how reactants arm
works is it possible to translate our
dynamic of now into some funky react
thing
yawn mm I mean you could certainly
implement that in JavaScript obviously
to translate it in some general way
that's that's much trickier I mean the
we talked about compiling will from
language to JavaScript right and then
well no we don't necessarily because it
could be calling out to yoga music Karen
oh yes okay you don't want to use a
kernel okay then um let's see yeah you
would have to replicate some of the
things that we implemented in the cloud
from that that's obviously implemented
and on desktop in terms of are making
dynamic evaluations and probably also
keeping track of the dependencies what
symbols have been used during the
evaluation and especially in the case
where that's the dynamic module variable
well so you're saying the bottom line
here is you could imagine being able to
extend this web item type thing to be
able to deal dynamics and to basically
translate our dynamic dependency stuff
into some JavaScript dynamic dependency
stuff certainly conceivable yup it's not
it will be a lot of work I think but it
could work okay so so let's let's try a
different concept here okay you know
what if we imagine that we will have a
thing like transmogrify whose function
is that it just takes two just like we
have notebook import for instance which
you know just takes a notebook and
treats it as a symbolic expression it
does things with it
if I mean is that a useful operation it
could be a useful operation to just have
something which takes a notebook and
turns it into with a whole collection of
rules sort of its closest approximating
you know embeddable HTML plus JavaScript
thing yeah I mean the reason that's a
useful thing in my mind is that if I
want to put something on WordPress I
don't believe what yawns output produces
would be accepted by WordPress well
that's different
whether WordPress can embed this but but
look what yon is doing is to make a
notebook that is a fully activatable
thing that can have computations done in
it and so on whereas what transmogrify
is doing and the first approximation is
it's for for viewing only like most HTML
right and it is convenient probably for
viewing only to make certain
transformations now so you know and I
can't believe that in modern times that
you know transmogrify probably has lots
of horrifying rules in it but the
framework of I mean you know what we
would end up with then is something like
um you know notebook transform or
something um that takes a notebook here
and a set of rules and what does it
output well I mean it could have thrown
out a commit what's a an XML object well
I would think it's more like an HTML I
mean it could be a web item that it
outputs I think I'd like to see HTML
elements well come out of
transmogrifying I mean even without the
rules that could give you an XML object
which you could then anybody could
figure out how to apply transformations
on well you say there's only default
rules and that would be some kind of
thing I don't think about is so level I
think it wants to be as high level as
possible the thing outputs by default
should be as high level as possible
um I mean really what you're saying
though is that this is a specific thing
to the web I mean this is kind of
notebook to web right that's that's what
you're talking about there and I don't
even know I have no idea how did the out
of the links work and a transmogrify
page did Janice lemon I'm asking if I
have a whole directory like we do in
documentation I have a whole directory
of notebooks and I want to create what I
ultimately deployed URLs links how does
that work
third base I guess there are ways to
convert every link of frass there's
their lower camel the other local no no
but what do you mean they're local
they're not local when they're deployed
on the web
well I mean they're they don't have the
eight they don't have absolute pathnames
correct yeah you can do it all relative
and then this farm does everything's to
play it didn't unison it'll work or if
you know where you're going you can do
them all absolute well but if you're
doing them absolute there's got to be
some rules because the absolute right
just wouldn't work right but like we
said there's you know infinitely many
hooks you can do just customize these
things um okay okay so I mean yeah okay
let me just read through this some of
these other comments here um
yeah Ethan is saying try evaluate all
cells in this cloud notebook
okay and he predicts that it's going to
be absolutely horrifying
okay let's try it
you
something's happening there
um okay Colonel will most likely die he
says silently and then if you try and
rerender the nope and then try to
rerender the notebook
why did it why did it leave those out
see that
know that intelligible definitely used
to be a bug where it would use the wrong
order um but I think that should be
fixed Iman for nine are those not
strictly input cells because they have a
different style sheet coming from jockey
tools it must be it must be a look it
must have it must be the right thing
because it got the right output here
kind of they're just inputs I don't
think we are seen in the games with
those I look at this this is now working
so that didn't work in the cache but it
does work here like a making sense well
not in the cache you I think you were
already thing that the life version why
I understand but it didn't work before
oh I see um reevaluation it worked yeah
what is that that is a bug hello
everybody that's a bug somebody should
report that is this might be a version
12 thing oh that's right that's right
there there's a version 12 page and that
is incorrect for version 12 yes yep okay
well I would say this is not doing to
straddle II so far except for the
weirdness of except for this weirdness
with with these ends not coming out
correctly but okay so the the prediction
of Ethan there on the live stream will
yet see we're only halfway through it
may still be correct um but it's going
pretty well here next is gonna dairy to
see how many chicken nuggets you need in
an hour or something right okay um
they saying you should probably use a
virtual DOM
maybe that was in relation to the
scrolling what we talked about I think
that's when they came in yeah okay so
someone here is complaining also gosh
I'm trying to use people's first names
but it's really impossible when that one
that's a jumble of letters here SP is is
saying that um Matt if I copy pasted the
notebook instead of publishing cells
cells would not run if we copy pasted
the large lump of cells here so that's
that's a that has not been dealt with
Leon of copy pasting from the desktop to
multicellular that direction
unfortunately no it's trickier than it
might seem and John Folse can't speak
about that but there's some risk in you
know we would have to populate the HTML
clipboard and deliver for the cloud but
then other applications might happen
something unexpected yeah yeah that's it
that's exactly correct we can only do it
by put it on the HTML clipboard which
then everybody will know about which
means we have to get the HTML clipboard
not just correct for the cloud but
correct for anybody who wants to look at
the HTML clipboard we have to have a
really good HTML export right but that
HTML export has to be too way it has to
be reconstructive or from that well
being able to reconstruct the cloud is
no problem because we could just include
the full notebook expression
yes in the metadata but but the problem
is is that I mean we if we did that and
only that and you know somebody like you
know maybe you like Microsoft Word or
something would say oh you have an HTML
clipboard well I'll paste that you know
I I don't actually know if Microsoft
Word does that but there are programs
out there that will do that so right so
we have to decide we have to be clear
what's going to be on there and in fact
we might people might actually be
happier to not see the HTML
yeah and there is some hope though I
mean browser vendors are working on
better AP is for the clipboard and so at
some some point we might be able to can
we detect it there's a problem
John I mean in other words when we when
we are about to or yawn when we're about
to paste this thing that came from a
multicellular sort of paid copy in the
desktop and then you try and paste it
into the cloud what does it actually do
it will you know be whatever you would
get when pasting into a plain text
editor will be my invest the best that
we can do is apply heuristics to the
plain texts by the way why is this not
and there hold on something went wrong
something went wrong I hope I hope it
might have been exactly what Ethan said
that the something went wrong here look
well this is no longer at some point the
kernel did thigh apparently yeah I just
didn't tell us
Oh what state we're in now I mean well
oh you're in and out prompt sir on
unnumbered so that confirms the colonel
died yes I understand but I don't think
it produced anything too terrible out
here so far as I understand it I mean
there's nothing unless unless this is
now not going to work I would this not
be working that should be not be a
particularly slow thing is this now
totally hosed no it seems to working
fine there I say it just took a little
while okay so I'm not sure
I mean yes the colonel died although we
were probably asking it to do a lot it
would have been nice I mean it might
have been nice to have some indication
that that had happened beyond mmm-hmm um
some notifier or something yeah
okay but I mean it doesn't look like it
did any particular harm here um okay
now another note here one shout out to a
local deploy option for API functions um
yes
okay best way to allow okay so this
relates to this comment from turbo
this relates to things we've been
discussing about web engine and so on
asking for a
um
[Music]
well asking I think for a local deploy
that allows you on your machine to have
something which serves api's that is
exactly what a web engine and our
application server direction are about
um best way to learn option to let local
deploy behind an engine X or
general-purpose server like caddy well
I've not heard of caddy I've heard
engine heck of engine acts um
uh well I think that's for a different
set of people to discuss unless unless
yon wants to make out anybody else wants
to make a comment on that I think the
answer is we are very much going in this
direction and I believe we will be
providing what you're asking for
I hope um oh I see oh but you're asking
well local notebooks accessing local
api's Wow
that's even a different case because
let me to understand something with one
of the things you were previously saying
okay yan can you imagine having
no you you can't have without the whole
cloud infrastructure you can't have a
locally presented
web-browser readable cloud notebook
it isn't in the cloud did that make any
sense you could I mean similar to HTML
export you could generate the HTML once
and take care of serving all the the
image files and style sheets and so on
and then you would have a static view of
the notebook but once you want what
about the activity right so I think what
what's being asked here by in this
question is in that case could one have
the interactivity call a local server
like the wolf
several web engine rather than calling
the cloud it won't immediately work it's
something we can think about but for
many things we need that Java layer in
between right now
which basically is the cloud right
right okay for you know for some simple
things you probably wouldn't be too hard
to make JavaScript called it curl
directly or maybe through some very
lightweight thing in the middle but but
there are many edge cases where it
really needs to travel code right now
all right okay so another comment the
notebook and better will be nice with a
read-only mode I think they're not
looking better unfortunately is a
read-only thing is that not correct if
it doesn't report editing or evaluation
or hotels but it does support
interactivity of say manipulate and you
can choose whether you want to enable
that or not how do you choose that um
well both two things you need to enable
interactivity on the notebook itself by
giving permission so you'd say no all
goes to read and interact and then you
can also choose on the JavaScript client
side it you know in your when you use
the library in your JavaScript code you
can say whether you actually want to
enable interactivity or not okay all
right let's try and let's try and come
to some conclusions here okay so I think
thing is the sort of symbolic
description of HTML so we've got
these different levels of description
we've got plain text to the
jemelle plus inclusions we've got this
opaque Dom objects we've got the
symbolic HTML tree and we've got the web
item like elements so the obvious right
answer here is that they all that we
should support all of these things in an
interoperable way
that makes sense to people so that for
example the web item thing could contain
these lower level objects
that impossible I think that depends on
which approach to have item you mean no
I'm talking about Ricardo's web item
well in a way it's already implemented
like these I mean you can nest like web
buy them with maxima and use them inside
XML template or the other way around I
think okay so but is there a sense in
which I mean the HTML you you could end
up with it with a force to be top level
piece of HTML but if you do that and you
put that inside then it's not going to
work and that's your problem but I yeah
I mean it seems like supporting
something which allows you to specify
you know low level HTML either in one of
these three ways either as the plain
text of the HTML some kind of symbolic
HTML elements or something that I don't
know how how do you write out the okay
there's a naive question the HTML DOM
how does it serialize
or is the serialization an HTML page
what is the serialization of an HTML DOM
Your Honor somebody can use I mean
basically something very much like HTML
there are there are some technicalities
where it might make a difference like I
mean when we talk about the Dom it's
really did that the live document and
there of that so he presents you would
see event handlers in a Dom but not in
the serialized HTML what well not wait a
second so the question is when one is
reading like that nice github thing that
was reading HTML I'm now confused that
was ok so we believe that that could be
reading symbolic HTML elements but that
might not be efficient or some such
other thing what do we believe that it
has to be reading something which still
has handles to a Dom I don't know don't
know the library
okay but in any case so you know the
thing we're talking about here would be
finishing what Ricardo has with the
ability to put instead of his so Ricardo
you do you have a mechanism to put raw
HTML inside your web page specifications
is it okay so what's the difference then
between what we're looking at between
your what you have here which I did
think the design was largely finished
I'm sorry I'm remind me Eric you said
you didn't look at Ricardo stuff is that
right we did start taking a look at it
but we didn't quite understand
everything that's that was going on in
it but we haven't had a chance to really
do so what I think we should do is take
I mean your proto design seems pretty
thin to me it's just a symbolic
representation of the tree structure of
HTML is that not correct well it's kind
of like that but also trying to
illustrate the discussions I had with
Brad was especially revolve around kind
of WTI's work of creating very
customized web pages that we can then
pass off to content writers to be able
to you know use Wolfram language to put
in all the content
so basically WPA would build all these
web items that then any kind of
developer can just plop in and then run
the notebook and then suddenly they have
a web page that they can look at I don't
know that's that's basically saying that
there has to be a repository of web
templates there it's kind of a third
case that wasn't really discussed
earlier where Wolfram language is used
to generate content and as the build
process for a page or a site so sorry
what this is you said they're gonna go
to where the Wolfram language is used as
kind of the build process where you've
got you know your web developers and
Eric's group that put together this
structure you know in in terms they're
familiar with and then you know can pass
it off to other teams for content or
things like that I don't all you're
talking about there is in our hierarchy
here we're looking at
um sorry where was it
yeah you were just looking at this we're
just saying have a repository of useful
HTML templates that are written in
essentially our in HTML / XML with our
XML template inclusion representation
right that's what you're talking about
there you you want people to be able to
write big blobs of fancy HTML plus
JavaScript less CSS whatever code with
that is template able is that correct
since thinks though yeah okay so fine so
this is irrelevant to that because all
you want is they've got HTML code and
they can insert and they can you can
take sort of Wolfram language content
and insert it in that HTML template
right
but there's no reason for the HTML
template to have this structured
symbolic form it could do but it doesn't
need to have that form am i is can
somebody else help me am I am i
misunderstanding something or do I have
it correct well in the way so so we I
mean we could go with the path where W I
would write you know just files that
could be that contain but it was also a
kind of making it easier so that non
developers could also look at it and
understand what they I don't understand
what problem you're solving this so I
mean if you're solving the problem look
what would happen that's not what I
wanted at all the I'm typing into
completely the wrong thing I am looking
for this um okay
so you see these kinds of tags here
right so what I'm imagining is that
you're you know down in the trenches
HTML developer is writing HTML with
those tags in it that HTML becomes a
template stored in a repository that can
then be trotted out as something that is
either inside or outside Ricardo's stuff
in the making sense because what's
ultimately going to happen is that
things going to be run just using
template apply with certain content
that's being inserted in place of those
tags is that correct right anybody else
and so I don't understand what the so
the choice of whether to use a symbolic
representation of that xmi of that HTML
or a purely textual one seems completely
orthogonal to this question of what the
workflow is that not correct
somebody else Maalik symbolic think
would be you could import it to this
symbolic expression and make
modifications okay but you can okay
we're dealing with two things here you
can manipulate the raw HTML in an editor
yes okay so there's some purposes for
which it's a lot easier to do that if
you're just tweaking trivial things in
the HTML if you want to do something
programmatically it might well be easier
to do it in symbolic form right so so
now what we need is going between those
two things we need an importer and
exporter so we discussed the question of
HTML import which apparently is
inadequate and one of the things that we
could then do is import the HTML to this
symbolic form we're making sense yeah
and then if you want to you can
manipulate it in the symbolic form then
you could export it again you'll get the
textual form and that would be that
piece of the workflow does that make
sense to people
yep and presumably in the symbolic form
of the HTML you would be able to have
template elements that would then get
exported as those template tags does
that make sense should I say that again
no I understood sense to me I mean that
would be a goal yes right and in
symbolic form those are things like
templates lot right so in other words
what we're saying is if you import a
piece of let's call it enhanced HTML
wolfram enhanced HTML you know you know
Wolfram language tagged HTML
okay you understand Eric and Brad you
understand what I mean by that it's
symbolic HTML no no no no no no no I'm
saying I'm saying look that the case
there is we're taking um okay we'll take
what we're taking is let's say Wolfram
tagged a textual HTML okay do you
understand what I mean Eric you
understand what I mean by that there
already has some Wolfram placeholders in
it yeah that has these kinds of Eric do
you understand what I mean by that
okay so I mean that it contains stuff
like that right but it's otherwise
textual HTML right yep okay so then
isn't it T in HTML text I'm sorry I'm
well aware okay so it's like like ATM
machine looking for an example that's a
good one um okay okay so then so that's
one case is wolfram tag textual HTML
okay
another thing is WL symbolic HTML so
that is the thing that you were talking
about with HTML elements and all those
kinds of things does that make sense
and within symbolic HTML there would be
things like template slots in other
words the translation of this stuff
would be to template slot does that make
sense yes Eric you understand yep okay
so then those are those are two
of raw HTML and then the next level of
stuff is we've got you know
Ricardo's web item which is a beyond
just symbolic HTML it defines more
sophisticated things symbolically for
web pages makes sense and it can contain
either of these other things that make
sense okay so these are these things
here are the the content representations
okay okay then we've got the actions um
the
um let's see um
okay
the actions will be
let me see what are the action so the
actions are
okay so one action is resolved the
templating aka run template apply okay
and then the output of the resolving of
the templating so output is a pure HTML
file I believe
no it'd just be a snippet it could be a
snippet of HTML yeah or it could
probably be multiple files of a fragment
or multiple files I don't quite
understand how that works but but okay
yeah by the way there's another piece to
this which is um directories of the
above right because it might not be a
single file that you want that makes
sense
okay so resolving the templating is one
thing so
another thing so then then there's
actually oh boy
another another flow will be go go from
a raw notebook a pure notebook to some
web assets okay that's another thing we
want to do
yes
yes and there are two ways to do that
number one faithful faithful rendering
which is basically cloud technology and
the other is transformed rendering which
is basically transmogrify or some
version of that and we believe those are
two separate things that you might want
that make sense yes hmm yeah where you
say directories is that implying a site
representation of a site or is that
another thing yet maybe okay so okay so
what else do we need here so that
there's also things like so in the web
item there can be notebooks form
functions etc embedded right
so those web assets okay
the web assets may need okay so then the
next thing is execution environments or
deployment environments is importing
another action yes-yes-yes-yes import
from HTML to symbolic form okay so
deployment so the deployments of this
okay so one deployment is a file slash
directory of pure HTML well or well pure
HTML plus etc and this might need a
local nodejs
to run the JavaScript is that right or
it might just be a pure um or it might
be pure HTML so that's one one output
output what it generates is pure HTML -
- generated if we use the cloud
technology you would set any JavaScript
I see I see I see or you would call the
cloud that thoughts an option right you
could run it through the cloud and get
bacterium okay so faithful rendering
either happening through the cloud or
perhaps through local nodejs yep okay
okay and the transformed rendering would
be pure WL code that won't need any
other stuff because that's just gonna be
lumps of you know it's just gonna be
told this is there okay so the
deployment so first thing is a file
directory of pure HTML right which is
then runnable runnable that can be you
know ingestible by any browser I wonder
whether ingestible has another huh yes
no I thought that was the right spelling
come somebody find over it's a word and
if it is put in the spelling dictionary
um whose whose project managing here I'm
adjustable by any web-browser it is
indeed a word okay
is it a scrabble word John yes it is a
scrabble word okay let's put in the
dictionary but um okay
okay so that's one output right another
output is a cloud notebook living in the
cloud yes that's another thing that can
be output by these various you know
transformations or I mean if you want a
notebook then you don't need any
transformation but if you start with a
notebook
no you're right you're right that
doesn't make any sense sorry that
doesn't make any sense
okay now what about something what about
where is Ricardo's thing being served
from
okay so this I think is another thing a
servable webpage wow we're getting a lot
of words web page in the cloud so
Ricardo's thing was being served on some
totally weird domain that not correct
Ricardo fine mean it's on your local
machine just a minute
okay but so you then you are currently
falling into that output right the file
or directory of HTML that correct it's a
static yeah it's a steady compilation
process okay but but but I'm just trying
to understand what what it is that we
want to have happen here so this thing
you're making a directory of static
assets is that correct recorder
sure Lincoln saw transmogrifies doing
something single right
and it's completely study okay I think
that proof all of these flow okay okay
right all right but that can call api's
or embeddings in the cloud sometimes
right it might need to do that or it
might not
I can see a future where transmogrifier
I'm just asking about what you're what
you've got right now right what Ricardo
has it might need to call its obviously
pulling in URLs you know external URLs
and it could also pull in something
which is an embedded notebook that
correct
kado yes yes I mean this part of design
was solving a particular problem which
is the CSS that the visualization of the
HTML T how you do interaction it's
completely other you know dyneisha
well okay then the other thing we might
want is to be able to take what you have
record a web item and cloud deploy web
item
right you get what I'm saying and
there's there any problem with doing
that
no I mean I got laid or a TBI or or
anything that I understand I understand
but what I'm asking is your thing that
right now is being served out of a file
on your local machine there's no reason
you can't just say put that on the web
right showing your buddies yes maybe
that's the bride everywhere you want no
no no I understand but there's a piece
of plumbing that's not completely
trivial which is when you do that
deployment this Web item has to unfurl
itself in the cloud and it may unfurl
itself to multiple files for example
my making sense
when you do this when you render this
your functional test that was rendering
this okay it is writing a directory of
stuff there is a single page a single
view yes if you have like a yeah an ID
appeal right like a directory so what
I'm saying is cloud deploy has to be
able to write a directory into the cloud
which is then exposed through URLs on
the cloud right we have your eldest
partial footer which is dynamic and I
was like okay I remember the name that
there was static external bundles okay
fine so you're deploying an external
bundle this is assuming that there's not
a template needing arguments well if
it's a template then you're deploying an
API right right that's a whole other
case well okay but then okay so look a
an API that returns a servable web page
right so that would then look like a
cloud deploy of API function of
essentially web item that correct
Ricardo is that correct
so I think similar on the same length
yes right so what that would allow you
to do is dynamically create a website
with parameters that you will then see
right that allows you to generate this
thing dynamically but of course like if
you're an expert on it notice this is
generating thing dynamically I hope it
doesn't need a directory it can all be
in mind I have no idea I mean which is
why I would say you you need the
director if you are creating several
pages and might generate several pages
so you don't have a way if it is several
pages then it's you know this much then
and then like on the right hand side of
the URL dispatch even an ABI function
and then on the second event of you've
actually would like this this layout
being all right so listen I think we've
got the elements of a plan here okay um
can I'm not sure who's you know who's
exactly gonna take the lead on this
stuff I think we need to understand this
github thing with HTML import we need to
understand how those HTML elements
relate to anything the other ones I
wasn't particularly excited about Eric's
design I mean it's nice to see that
group starting to do these designs and I
perhaps shouldn't be more part not be as
negative about it I just would have
appreciated it if you guys had actually
looked at the other stuff before you
showed me that design um the it would be
good to try and see what will be a
minimal transmogrify design or mama I've
never even seen probably not for 20
years the design of transmogrify right
so so let's think about Andy on
attacking examples for us I mean there
might play into the project there Jase
as well which is what documentation
writing no no no no no no no okay the
authoring side has always been
completely separate from the conversions
okay and will remain so that's not okay
that's all that discussion yeah second
right okay so here okay so I'd like to
see some some sort of presentation of
what is there now and what we could put
or we could build in the future and
obviously one thing we want to be able
to do is to transport over the giant
transmogrify rule towers let's call them
that are used for our actual
documentation so that any modern version
of transmogrify we could just use those
without having to find the next god
knows how many years
finding um you know little detailed
things that weren't moved over correctly
am I making sense
and II you understand what I'm saying
yes I understand um are you saying
that's totally unrealistic to yourself
well I think we're both taking breaths
okay just because well into this stuff I
know but I'm saying I'm saying use all
that and use all that I know what you're
saying yeah yeah don't don't try and
think we're gonna rebuild it because
we're not
there's no yeah an outer layer that can
potentially take this big blob of
complicated rules and use them but has a
cleaner outer layer okay um and then
meanwhile yon has got to figure out how
to generate from in in this one the
faithful rendering version how to
generate a complete HTML page from that
and that's probably the future of HTML
export
no making sense um
what you mean I mean go to that no no if
you're rendering in the cloud
I'm talking about the cash being a
complete HTML cash okay yup there we can
do right so that's it that's another
piece to this right because that's the
piece that we need in order to make an
HTML export that just runs through the
cloud
mm-hmm right which might be localizable
as well but that less of a priority or
think so I think it's that I think well
I don't know I I think it's less of a
priority I think it would be okay to run
that through the cloud okay um as long
as the result you get back works
independently of the cloud so you still
want to get a directory that has all the
assets yes and thank you but the clouds
are serviced to get that to you right
approach right and and and it may have
trailing pieces that actually require
the cloud like the manipulate may not
run unless you have it connected to the
cloud and those kinds of things so it
will try to provide you localizable
assets as much as it can but some of
them may trail and be left in the cloud
is that correct
it I mean the HTML cartridge in itself
will not try to run a manipulate at all
um I'm not I'm not saying that I'm
saying in the end you're getting this
thing that is a rendering of a notebook
in HTML okay if the notebook has a man
appear ITIN it what is going to be in
the HTML
display of the manipulate okay but could
it not be an embedded notebook an
embedded cloud notebook of them an
appeal light oh it could be I mean not
hard works now so we have to make some
changes I need to think about how that's
right but so I'm saying that would be a
super cache so to speak right so so
there are different versions here you
know this could either be either um
HTML from the cloud that has only local
elements localized elements or local
elements or could have embeddings that
point back to the cloud make sense and
that's analogous in HTML export I
believe we have some options well we
used to have those options to do with
being able to have plugins I mean that's
the analog of the old plug-in options
right so in other words either you just
get a bitmap or you get something which
points through a quotes plugin except
that this is now an embedded cloud view
to the cloud um okay we have a couple
comments on the livestream here if
you're using an XML template you don't
have a director of templates you have
one template and a big list of data
which creates a directory of output
don't understand that I thought an XML
template will just give you one foe ICU
you want to run the XML template across
you like doing a file system scan for
example across a bunch of things yeah I
don't think there's a problem with that
okay
all right I actually think we have
unscrambled a lot of things here um all
right so we are gonna need to finish
Ricardo stuff as I've said multiple
times looks like it's in pretty good
shape already um there are going to be a
bunch of corner cases about embedding we
have still not completely solved the
three forms on a page problem right
Ricardo
to some extent yes there are multiple
solution to this problem
but we need a solution okay but I think
we've got some you know path forward
here now I mean just to be clear none of
what we're describing here has any way
of solving the panels and the desktop
problem is that a correct statement
yes we started with a uniform design
that was going from to the web but then
then we realized that the web guitar is
own language is completely different and
forcefully from none of these things
using electron or any of these other
technologies would allow us to do this
because of sandboxing between browser
worlds and you know executables is that
correct that's a more a question for
John and folks and so on is correct yeah
so the only way you could work around
that is by running an insecure web
server which is not something that I
would recommend hold on let's just walk
through that for one second imagine that
you had a local web server running okay
that was insecure in the sense of that
it's web pages could call out to a
binary yeah could that which is to say
that you would have to modify the web
server itself to do that well but I mean
when you say web server you make it
sound very fancy I mean the minimal web
server is a tiny piece of code this
doesn't have to be remember all the
technologies in the browser that's where
all the fancy rendering and so on is
taking place what you're saying is let's
just walk through this for one second so
start local web server right we've
already got that technology and I don't
know what that server is that server is
some totally minimal server right is
that correct
is that the girl saying I think it might
be Ricardo can you speak to that is not
it's not exposing system and the
implementation was unfortunately like
not super stable so we never what are
you asking now sorry I'm asking okay web
server is not a symbol in
okay all right fine can I can I actually
run it or not you need to get the pocket
is called HTTP and link back thick and
desktop that is working okay hold on
hold on so actually John I think this
sounds extremely promising
okay so let's walk through this idea for
one second okay
imagine we go from start web server
right and imagine that that web server
which is a very minimal web server I
mean the thing that was written in go is
some tiny little piece of code right and
we have a yes web server which is as you
say insecure that is a pure quotes web
page can access you know our our whole
computation system can delete files on
your system yeah literally do anything
it won't yeah just like if you have a
raw notebook open it can do anything it
wants right within a raw notebook I
could say delete file star yeah right
this is a raw notebook this is for
individual users doing things this is
not intended to be deployment this is
this is saying you've opened a notebook
you can do whatever you want the only
difference here is that the notebook you
opened has some web assets around it so
my question would be in that scenario
okay I'm still confused here what you
can do what you can't do so we couldn't
so serve a cloud notebook is that true
because that's a whole pile of other
technology to do that that's basically
an EPC right okay so just to understand
if you had an EPC
if an EPC were a thing that you could
just you know install onto your local
computer and run it without too much
efforts and too and too much you know
resource usage then then you would have
to have a hacked web server for the EPC
and then what you could do is run I mean
of course of course
you could do this you know without a
hacked web server you would just be
living inside the sandbox the EPC
defines for you which you know doesn't
filesystem necessarily give you your
filesystem okay so look this is in a
sense a null statement because what it's
basically saying is Annie Annie PC is
providing the whole cloud environment in
the cloud environment you can do all
these things yeah that what we're trying
to get is something where you can have
paneling so to speak around a
traditional desktop notebook right and
maybe that's just hopeless you know that
is its plug in territory basically and
there's no way even if you control the
web server and you decide we're
perfectly happy to have plugins because
it's just a single user doing their
thing is there any way to do it other
than just absurd hackery I think we're
into absurd hackery I mean the could you
create some kind of web server side
plug-in that tries to kind of act like a
browser plug-in did maybe it would be
probably very slow and probably have all
kinds of problems with the rendering
cannot be through the web browser so the
rendering has to be native desktop
notebook yeah you know the way the the
way the Mac browser front-end worked was
literally by pushing bitmaps back and
forth but in that case is pushing
bitmaps back and forth over math leg so
the actual browser plugin was basically
nothing it was two things one was it was
a thing which knew how to display
bitmaps and communicate you know receive
those bitmaps from a genuine front-end
and two it was a thing which knew how to
relay events like keyboard events that
kind of thing to the front end total
hacker I mean that's like Vance rut
running VNC or something
[Music]
but that was that was what we had to do
so why is that not repeatable in other
words that particular model insane
though it is of essentially running VNC
from inside your browser well the I mean
you know an actual VNC requires you know
requires a machine that you're that
you're displaying yeah I didn't mean
that exactly but I mean something with
that kind of protocol the in fact in
fact let me ask this question within a
browser is it not the case that you can
do like I mean things like zoom and
screen sharing applications in general
don't they use some protocol which I now
forget web web what is it is it web
no what is the protocol that's used i I
don't know the protocol but I but I know
the idea that you're talking about
though within I mean clearly so I mean
these things yeah I mean basically what
you would have to do is you would have
to have a virtual desktop that's you
know that can be mirrored in in some way
and that would be a pretty non-trivial
and then mirrored you know through a web
server and that you know that would be a
pretty non-trivial piece of technology
right well it sounds like so you know
you know VNC and zoom and and those
kinds of things your honor they they
have the benefit of you know that
they're at least working with an
existing desktop
yeah and it's done so okay
look clearly these solutions are
probably even more complicated than
actually building out paneling in the
notebook desktop environment yeah which
is what I would much rather be doing
yeah well I think you're right I mean I
so a question then for you John is if
you look at Ricardo's web item design is
it you know what's the level of insanity
of connecting that I mean so some of
what we're cruising to do there is very
CSS specific right well and the and
sorry I wasn't prepared to answer this
question but there is a there's a
library that Facebook has that that you
can basically you know plug this these
CSS type specifications into it and get
out a bunch of rectangles you know that
you don't have to do all of the layout
yourself where layout is defined as you
know this equals you know how many
pixels by how many pixels for yellow
good so it's replicating it's a it's a
more modularized version of what CSS
month does inside yeah yeah where where
the layout compensations are concerned
yes and so I'm I'm counting on the fact
although you know we've not run any
experiments but I'm counting on the fact
that whether it's Facebook's library or
somebody else doing something similar
that you know that there will be you
know some
see compatible library out there that we
can use to do this now as far as you
know the multi window management we're
just gonna do you know that's just the
hard work we're gonna have to do but the
layout I'm hoping that I'll have to do
that so then if we're gonna use a CSS
inspired layout engine anyway having you
know working at Ricardo's in Ricardo's
system with things that fall down into
raw CSS doesn't seem that horrifying
right we should probably wrap it so that
if when we have a final you know we have
a symbolic abstraction of it we can use
that but I think we should allow people
to just use the raw CSS specifications
if they want to yeah and you know as you
know I mean these these layout things
you know they can be difficult to get
right because they turn into fixed point
problems yep I'm quite happy not to have
to rewrite that yeah and I think also
honestly people are used to the CSS way
of doing it even if the CSS has bugs
with respect to how it does the
fixed-point computations yeah people are
at least used to those bugs yeah um I
don't think that's a problem we have to
solve all right well this is great
then okay we're gonna need to allocate
resources to actually move forward on
this but I think we have a good
direction here um and I think I'm
convinced that yeah we shouldn't try
there's there's no hackery that's gonna
work here okay well thank you all very
much and thanks to people here thank you
to folks on the livestream a lot of
really really useful comments and
interaction here so until the next time
see y'all soon